jason kaplan who's like obese his doctor
said he's in perfect health
jason's in perfect health what is this
doctor taking into consideration
to be fair even i don't trust my doctor
like really
i keep waiting to be like all right now
we're going to put you on the blood
pressure medication you're like yeah you
know watch your salt a little bit
otherwise
you're doing great i mean this is a guy
who like barbecues a whole pig
remember when somebody was telling us
they went to some kind of uh
a meat festival literally
ate until he couldn't breathe howard
there's a part of it where i
i think jason literally at one point you
can hear him breathing heavy
and i think he says to whoever's with
him i feel my entire body shutting down
and he's fine he's got a clean bill of
health he'll go back and do it again
this is jason on pig island how are you
how you feeling
i'm getting a little short of breath
thing i was telling you about you know
it's getting a little stomach's getting
a little heavy to
get a little harder to breathe are you
sweating more would you say yeah
my pits are getting there under my belly
like under the
crease it's definitely getting a little
sweaty and i just feel my whole
i really do feel my whole body including
my mind kind of slowing up
right now like you're really driving
this train at this point
jason ate enough for two days of food
for an average adult he had
4 842 calories in four hours
wow like we clocked it because it's not
just the pork it's like it was you know
a half of it's in some sort of sweet
sauce
you know covered in butter there's pork
sausage there's pork sandwiches
uh there was pork sushi um yeah
you know it's not like you're getting
the same thing over and over again
everyone has a different
horrible unhealthy way to present it to
you when you get to them
here's a montage of jason eating at pig
island i got to play this for you you'll
love this
look at pork taco oh my god we got a
piece of sausage here a bratwurst
oh they just handed me chocolate to eat
with the prosciutto
we've got some japanese noodles i'm
eating roasted pork tacos from kingsley
mole carrot and onions sweet
oh this is a kabasa salami type deal oh
jesus christ it's like a like a pate or
something
oh the pork is perfect though oh my god
it's amazing
i know you're full and you've continued
eating any regrets no
ma'am we're here to do a job jason after
pig island
he jerked off when he came to his
barbecue sauce
you